one piece is simply the best manga of
all time i am rock hard right now this
is some 11 out of 10 peak fiction stuff
katakuri yamato marco shanks blackbeard
hancock and kobe how much better can one
piece get really oda sensei has blown
the door for a fantastic finale of the
story wide open with a ton of intriguing
and frankly unpredictable storylines
wide open the formation of cross guild
with crocodile mihawk and buggy teaming
up i think no one could have seen that
coming shanks finally becoming active
and joining the race falloff tale the
world government unleashing a truly
terrifying looking new weapon with the
seraphim and instead of robin or sabo or
vv being the new ace it ended up being
kobe the first of probably many more
upcoming provocations that will lead to
luffy having to face blackbeard in
battle and i do hope that you got
yourself a big big cup of coffee because
this will be a true blast breaking
everything down because every single
thing that happened in this chapter is
absolutely legendary and awesome and i
do want to begin with yamato as you will
remember yamato not joining the crew
costs him
let's say dissatisfaction with the
ending of wano for me and many others
and while i'm not saying that the
flashback we got here is making up for
all the criticism i had it definitely
has helped for instance i was very
disappointed that oda sensei made us
believe that he'd off-screen luffy's
conversation with yamato so i am very
grateful we finally got it in this
chapter as it turns out the reason
yamato isn't coming with luffy as she
clearly wanted to all along is not
because she suddenly wanted to sightsee
more of the place where she was kept
prisoner her entire life but to help
momonosuke protect wano in the absence
of kaido's presence it seems that
everyone has taken the yokogyu's words
very seriously that now that kaido is no
longer the rule of wano there is nothing
any more deterring powerful pirates or
the marines to attack the island and
come for its riches and it's road
poneglyph and so yamato has decided to
keep her true goal from momo in order to
not hurt his feelings for not being
strong enough yet to handle everything
on his own i think it's a very
reasonable decision that is a way better
explanation for yamato staying behind
than the sightseeing one you know and
i'm curious what yamato is going to do
with all the time that she now has in
wano i'm still sad that she didn't join
right away but i really really hope that
luffy will be coming back for her sooner
rather than later i want yamato to sail
with luffy and co a bunch and not just
one last time to love tail and obviously
it really
warmed my heart that luffy is once again
basically calling yamato a straw hat in
this chapter also i just realized this
week that luffy and marco did not
actually meet one single time during the
entirety of wano which came as a real
shock so i feel like oda sensei read my
mind here because marco actually comes
to say goodbye to luffy and the crew
once again being easily one of the
coolest characters in the entire series
i don't know why but he just has some of
the coolest lines like telling luffy
that it's his era now basically swearing
his allegiance here not that he really
needed to i mean he has risked his life
for luffy more than enough already to
prove that and then rubbing his
networking skills in our face even more
he takes off and flies on board of
shanks's ship bearing any last remaining
doubts really that shanks could be some
sort of villain even though the
interaction we get between him and the
retired pirates is pretty short here it
is so damn satisfying i don't know about
you but reading this i couldn't help but
grin all the way through it's so cool to
see the respect between these legends
and the way that they fool around with
each other i mean you can almost feel
the presence of roger and whitebeard's
friendly rivalry in the air here also
shanks asking marco a second time to
join his crew is hilarious you remember
that he did that before when he came to
talk to whitebeard about teach so no
wonder that teach is in this chapter as
well it also proves once again how
powerful and capable marco truly must be
everyone respects him and he has come
out of confrontations with all the
strongest people pretty much unharmed
and alive the admirals of marine fort
blackbeard big mom and kaido this man
truly is indestructible i would
personally put him in the same category
as ben beckman rayleigh or zorro who are
still not too far away in power to their
captains the wretched pirates then drop
marco off at sphinx island which i think
is actually really important because the
way that i read this chapter this
basically means that luffy and the straw
hats won't be going to sphinx island
after all as some people have speculated
i mean if that were the case i feel like
marco would have said something about
meeting again or something similar or
even sail with the straw hats right away
i mean that doesn't mean that sphinx
island is off the table completely as
the next island or that luffy will never
go there i mean i really hope they do
visit aces and whitebeard's grave but i
personally still hope and believe that
the straw heads are going to albaf next
and not law or kids i laid out all the
reasons for that in this video here so
check that out later if you're
interested because as much as i'd love
to speculate more about the straw hat's
next adventure we don't have time for
that right now we have to move on from
one of my top 5 favorite characters
marco to one of my top three characters
the dark king himself
silver's rayleigh i am so so happy that
we got him back in the story again way
sooner than i personally dare to hope i
gotta say this entire plot line that we
got on amazon lilly is so
so good like what not only do we get a
battle sequence we get one with some of
the coolest characters in the show
hancock who we haven't seen get serious
at all before this and blackbeard who
barely gets any screen time at all to
show off his ridiculously overpowered
devil fruit and of course kobe who let's
be real has grown a lot but is clearly
not quite yet on that level necessary to
make any real impact here but let's
start from the beginning we basically
get a continuation of the little
interlude we got during wano where kobe
was sailing towards amazon lilly in
order to capture boa hancock parallel to
the events of the raid there seemed to
have been a battle between the navy
fleet and the kuja tribe now usually
hancock and her warriors would probably
easily have overpowered the marine
troops here however they haven't come
alone we finally get the first glimpse
at the result of the ssg the special
science group and the weapons that they
created to replace both the pacifista
and the warlords the seraphim and holy
smokes oda sensei really didn't fool
around with their design here they are
absolutely terrifying asenav which
according to wikipedia literally means a
burning one is a type of celestial or
heavenly being in judaism islam and
christianity they're basically the
highest rank of angels with terrible
powers apparently their winged
appearance also has origins in ancient
egypt and so looking at oda sensei
seraphim this naming scheme makes a lot
of sense because they all look like
members of king's lunarian tribe with
white hair wings and dark skin they have
star-shaped pupils which any good anime
lover will know is the global sign that
someone is ridiculously powerful in case
you know bungo stray dogs there is a
child character as well with a star eye
called yumena kyusuku if i remember
correctly that has a pretty terrifying
power as well now clearly these new
humanoid weapons are a combination of
different types of research that we have
seen throughout the story kuma cyborg
technology the research conducted on a
young king before he was rescued by
kaido and interestingly enough genetic
research involving the former warlords
the two seraphim that we see do look a
lot like a young mihawk and as they
mentioned themselves a young boa hancock
a truly terrifying mix of abilities
honestly as you will remember the
lunarians were once called the gods that
lived on top of the red line they do
look like angels and they are able to
naturally conjure fire so the naming
scheme here is more than fitting they
truly are the burning ones and i think
it's reasonable to speculate that these
kids are growing faster than normal as
well so we might well see them as fully
grown adults by the end of the story
which would also be kind of terrifying
though let's be real the fact that their
children
might make them even worse and harder to
fight and so with the help of these two
the marines have made significant
progress towards the core of the islands
when our big boy blackbeard arrives at
the island to kind of like blast the
party once again turns out he was not
actually on his way to whole cake island
to get his hands on big mom's
unprotected poneglyph but to get boa's
devil fruit which i found an awesome
twist we all know that boy hancock was
truly powerful but the fact that
blackbeard thinks that her devil fruit
power is so important and necessary that
she can't let the marines have it
instead is such a cool reveal really i
really wonder why he wants it so badly
though i mean we can see how devastating
it is here but still i saw someone
speculate that maybe this fruit has
something to do with rocks because you
know it can turn people literally into
rock interesting idea i think i also
think that people tend to think that
hancock's middlemen me requires the
victim to fall in love or lust after the
user but i think it's also very possible
that you can simply use the fruit with
any strong emotion towards the user and
i mean people really do tend to hate
blackbeard which would then work pretty
great or he intended to give it to
katarina devon who can then imitate
hancock that would actually be pretty
smart though we still don't know if just
anyone can theoretically eat two devil
fruits using blackbeard's method or if
it's something special about his body
and so he's now been patiently waiting
to come for this specific devil fruit
just like he did for the yami yaminomi
and the guraguranomi blackbeard is
basically playing fanfiction here he's
going oh you know if i was a character
in one piece i would not just want one i
want three devil fruits and i want the
three most awesome ones really love the
way of thinking and i think it's super
intriguing to see that blackbeard not
only has haki which we literally see him
use for the very first time here but
that he also knows about the lunarian
race clearly teach knows quite a lot
about the true history and the mysteries
of the one piece world i think both of
these things make him even more
dangerous if anything and scarier as a
villain to luffy than he already was at
that point and i think it's just perfect
that hancock is so strong that only
blackbeard can stop her here i always
thought that she was a pretty
underestimated character among fans
anyways and then we have this also very
interesting exchange between blackbeard
and kobe i mean you know before teach
them kidnaps him apparently teach was
there during the rocky port incidents
that involved both law and kobe as you
recall and more importantly a former
member of the rox pirates that was
unaccounted for so far was also there
ochoku he was still alive and apparently
the ruler of beehive island after rox's
downfall cheech defeated him and took
over the islands now why this was only
possible thanks to kobe i have no clue i
just really want to know what went down
really during the rocky port incident
now before teach can do anything to
hancock though my man
rayleigh pulls out a double shanks first
he makes his presence known with his
haki just like shanks did with green
bull and he basically stops another war
on amazon lilly without even raising a
finger just you know how shanks did
during the war at marinefords i guess
once a roger pirates always a roger
pirates this man is just way too badass
he just faces the likes of kizaru or
blackbeard with the coolness of aokiji's
ice powers
can't get enough of this man how badass
can one person be well let's be honest
you know as well as me that the most
baddest person is whoever has subscribed
to this channel easy clearly blackbeard
was not interested in fighting hancock
and rayleigh at the same time here plus
his crewmates would have died if he
killed boa hancock though we don't
really know if it would actually care
and so teach and the marines leave the
island and apparently teach took the
chance to take kobe during that
withdrawal super curious about this
plotline and how it will play out
because who will come to kobe's eight
the marines sword garb luffy maybe a
team-up between luffy and his
grandfather huh doesn't that sound
awesome or maybe blackbeard will simply
cash in kobe's bounty with cross guild
and hands him back over to elvita poor
guy let's hope that doesn't happen as if
all of this wasn't enough however we
also get the reveal that shaki was
actually the former empress of the kuja
tribe which for me was such a mind blow
moment but makes so much sense when you
really stop and think about it she does
look like she could be boa's older
sister or her aunt or something and she
helped the three sisters after they
escaped the celestial dragons it also
explains why she decided to stay at
sabah odi where she could keep an eye on
amazon lilly and come to the help of her
home if necessary i'm still convinced
though that despite that fact she was
still part of some sort of pirate crew
hopefully rocks so much hype the seda
theme once again proved just how much
oda sensei loves to include myths and
religion into the story he did the same
for sun god nika and even zoro and his
asuda powers if you want to know
how and what it means for the story then
you really shouldn't miss out on that
video right here